نقلت صحيفه ول ستريت جورنال عن مسؤولين
امريكيين ان المفاوضين الامريكيين يضغطون
من اجل التوصل الى اتفاق هدنه يمكن ان
يوقف الحرب في غزه لفتره كافيه لايقاف
الزخم العسكري الاسرائيلي وربما يمهد
الطريقه لهدني اكثر استدامه وقالت الصحيفه
ان المفاوضين الامريكيين يقولون انه سيكون
من الصعب على اسرائيل استناف الحرب بقوتها
الحاليه بعد توقف
طويل
معنا من رام الله مدير مكتب الجزيره وليد
العمري تصريحات عديده ولكن الثابت هو ان
نتنياهو يعتمد خطابين في التعامل مع اي
صفقه مقبله ما تفاصيل ما يمكن ان تفضي
اليه هذه المفاوضات وفق ما يتم تناوله في
الاوساط
الاسرائيليه اولا التصريحات التي ادلى بها
رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي نتنياهو في ثلاث
مناسبات ثلاث مرات خلال 24 ساعه الماضيه
وحدد فيها خطوطا حمراء اعتبرها كثيرون
بانها تاتي لعرقله المفاوضات وليس
لتسهيلها في جميع الاحوال نتنياهو دعا
مجلسي الطاقم الوزاري الامني السياسي
المصغر الذي يضم 17 وزيرا من كافه احزاب
الائتلاف وحكومه الطوارئ والمعروف
بالكابينه لاجتماع مساء اليوم كما انه دع
مجلس الحرب ايضا الاجتماع وهذه الاجتماعات
ستبحث منحى المطروح لابرام صفقه تبادل وفق
ما كان قد قدمه من احاطه رئيس المساد
الاسرائيلي الى الطاقم الوز الى مجلس
الحرب قبل يومين وايضا رئيس جهاز الشباك
الذي كان قد انهى جوله من المباحثات ايضا
في مصر في اليومين الماضيين لكن تصريحات
نتنياهو الحاليه حسب الاسرائيليين هي
موجهه الى قاعدته الانتخابيه والى حلفائه
المتطرفين جدا من الصهيونيه الدينيه وقوه
يهوديه لمار بن كبير وسموت الذان يهدد
خاصه بن كبير الذي يهدد بالانسحاب ولذلك
تاتي مثل هذه التصريحات ليشير فيها
نتنياهو بانه باق على خطوطه الحمراء كما
اسماها لكن من يقرا تصريحاته يرى بان
اسرائيل لا يبدو انها مرتاحه للمنحه الذي
انتهت اليه المفاوضات او جلسه القمه لرجال
الامن في كل
ورئيس حكومه قطر ومصر والولايات المتحده
وايضا اسرائيل في باريس قبل بضعه ايام هذه
التصريحات تاتي لتهيئ ايضا وتمهد
للمباحثات التي سيجريها وزير الخارجيه
الامريكيه بلينكن الذي سيصل المنطقه في
يوم السبت مساء في زياره هي السادسه
وستبحث ايضا محاوله تحريك المفاوضات
المتعلقه بابرام صفقه تبادل وبالمقابل
ايضا محاوله الوقوف على الرؤيه
الاسرائيليه لليوم التالي للحرب وهو ما
يتهرب منه نتنياهو المعلومات المتسربه في
اسرائيل حول المنحى المعروض هو انه يكون
هناك بالدفعه الاولى الافراج عن نحو 35
الى 40 رهينه اسرائيليه محتجزه في قطاع
غزه وفي مقابل كل رهينه منها يكون هناك
يوم وقف اطلاق نار اي نحو
35 الى 40 يوم هدنه ومن ثم نحو اسبوع
لاجراء مباحثات تمهيديه لتنفيذ المرحله
الثانيه المرحله الاولى تشمل المرضى
النساء والاطفال والمتقدمين بالسن الثانيه
المرضى والرجال والثالثه ستكون ايضا
للجنود الاسرى لدى حركه حماس وفي مقابل
ذلك كله يكون هناك افراج عن دفعات كبيره
تقدر بالمئات وربما بالالاف من الاسرى
الفلسطينيين المحتجزين لدى اسرائيل على ان
يشمل ذلك اسرى وازن مثل عباس السيد وعبد
الله البرغوثي من قاده كتائب القسام في
الضفه الغربيه والمحكومين لعشرات
المرات المؤبده وكذلك مروان البرغوثي
وا وسعدا واحمد سعدات من فتح والجبهه
الشعبيه وهو ما ترفضه اسرائيل اسرائيل في
مقابل ذلك تقول ان لديها منحى اخر قدمته
وهو ان يشمل على السماح لسته من قاده
القسام وحماس بالهج الرحيل عن قطاع غزه
وان يكون هناك تسليم لاسلحه حماس
بالكامل على ان لا يبقى لها وجود مسلح في
قطاع غزه وهو ما تدرك بانه مرفوض بشكل
قاطع من قبل قياده حماس والقسام تحديدا
لان حسب مصادرها تذكر ان الاسماء السته هي
يحيى السنوار وشقيقه محمد ومروان عيسى
ومحمد ضيف واخرين من كبار القاده ويؤكد
تعرض ذلك ويؤكدون في نفس الوقت
الاسرائيليون بان ال يحيى السنار لن يقبل
باي حال من الاحوال مثل هذا الخيار وهو ما
معناه ان
هناك حراك ولكن ليس هناك اختراق في هذه
المفاوضات المتعلقه بابرام صفقه تبادل
جديده نتنياهو في خطابه من جهه يخاطب ال
قاعدته الانتخابيه وحلفائه من اليمين الم
متطرف الذين يرفضون ويريدون المضيه في هذه
الحرب حتى نهايتها لان لدى اسرائيل على ما
يبدو با او لديه او انها اتخذت ذريعه من
احداث السابع من اكتوبر لخلق او
لايجاد تغيير ديموغرافي وجغرافي في قطاع
غزه وهو ما تدلل عليه استمرار حربها
والمقابر الجماعيه التي عثر عليها
والاعدامات الجماعيه التي تمت هناك ومن
جهه اخرى يحاول ان يقول لذوي الاسرائيليين
المحتجزين في قطاع غزه انه يفعل كل ما
بوسعه من اجل اعاده ابنائهم المختطفين من
رام الله مدير مكتب الجزيره وليد العمري
شكرا جزيلا لك